does the current corona virus pandemic
make it necessary that the federal
government tighten restrictions on
immigration that was the subject of an
online so how form debate held on
Wednesday May 6 2020 mark Krikorian the
executive director of the Center for
Immigration Studies defended the claim
that we need closed borders because of
kovat 19 against George Mason University
economist Brian Kaplan and here's Mark
Krikorian vs. Bryan Caplan in an online
debate moderated by Soho forum director
Jean Epstein
tonight's resolution reads the current
pandemic makes it all the more necessary
for the federal government to tighten
restrictions on immigration defending
the resolution mark Krikorian opposing
the resolution Bryan Caplan when each of
you has five minutes and one minute
remaining in your allotted time I'll be
briefly interrupting to inform you Jane
please close the initial vote now mark
Krikorian
who goes first defending the affirmative
is executive director of the Center for
Immigration Studies and author of the
new case against immigration and I'll
introduce Bryan in due course
take it away mark the issue it seems to
me in tightening immigration policy in
the current pandemic is not a health
related issue it's I mean actually most
travel has already been shut down it's a
labor issue that in other words is the
effects the consequences of our reaction
to the pandemic that make it imperative
to tighten up on immigration at least
temporarily and then we can have a
debate on the rest of it later as in
medicine so in practical governance the
first principle has to be first do no
harm
prudence in other words and prudence is
called for in our reaction to the
economic consequences of the current
crisis 30 million people have applied
for filed for unemployment since the
Wuhan virus arrived here on our shores
and the numbers of new claims from last
week will be reported tomorrow
and then on Friday the Labor Department
will report the monthly unemployment
rate for April we're gonna see an
extraordinarily high rate of
unemployment possibly in May and
probably possibly for April possibly
even in May the highest rate any of us
has ever seen in our lifetimes and may
ever see again and unlike the Great
Depression which where unemployment took
several years actually to grow what
we've seen today is a dislocation of the
labor market that happened in the blink
of an eye unfortunately it's not going
to recover in the blink of an eye an
economy is an organic thing it's not a
light switch you can turn on and off at
will and so it's going to take years to
recover economically from the
consequences of this virus especially
when you consider the changes in
hospitality and retail and entertainment
and air travel and a whole lot of other
industries that are now going to
essentially reboot but in a very
different way in other words it's not
the everyone who lost a job is just
going to show up again you know in a
month on Monday and then that's the end
of its there's gonna take years to
recover from nothing like this has ever
happened in our history and possibly
never in history of any other country so
regardless of broader views on
immigration and Brian I've debated that
I was delighted to come to the soho
forum and talk about that and i'd be
happy to do it again but regardless of
our broader views prudence demands that
we take vigorous steps to tighten
immigration in the current situation so
as to ease
the reintegration of those of our fellow
citizens whose livelihoods have been
destroyed by the response to this virus
and whether it was excessive or not
that's a different question it's
happened and the question is what do we
do with it now and remember these are
disproportionately not the sort of
people who are watching or participating
in this debate we're talking about
people who are disproportionately less
skilled people who have fewer options
even in the best of times finding their
way back into the world of work is gonna
be hard enough they don't need two
million new foreign workers every year
coming in to compete against we have and
we will have for some time a glut of
Labor in our economy let's not add to it
the legacy news media have reported that
President Trump has essentially already
done this in a presidential proclamation
last month it's a kind of executive
order I don't know why they call it that
instead of an executive order but in any
case don't believe everything you read
as we all should have learned over the
past several years the proclamation did
reiterate the principle underlying our
immigration laws and let me just quote
from that it from the proclamation in
the administration of our nation's
immigration system we must be mindful of
the impact of foreign workers in the
United States labor market particularly
in an environment of high domestic
unemployment and depressed demand for
labor unquote so far so good
unfortunately other than that this
Proclamation really didn't do much at
all despite the president's tweet the
day before touting it what happened is
the exceptions essentially consumed the
rule so that according to our
calculations this 60 day emigration
caused so-called applies to only about
5% of green-card issuances and all those
green cards are lawful permanent
residents of which total about 1 million
a year and 0 percent of the nearly 1
million guest workers supposedly
temporary workers
admitted every year now the president
did hint that there might be a follow-up
proclamation in 30 days from whatever
reissued it so in a couple more weeks
limiting some gas worker programs but
the nature of that measure is undecided
it's still up in the air from what I'm
hearing and it's the subject of fierce
wrangling inside the White House between
the high immigration forces and the low
immigration forces and the reason for
that is the reason I have little hope
that the council of prudence will
prevail in the White House is that again
contrary to the fairy tales that the
legacy media and the establishment
organs like The Times and CNN would have
you believe the president is not an
immigration restriction and neither are
most of his advisors or his staff not
just the son-in-law but it's throughout
the whole administration that said what
steps would prudence suggest I'll touch
on a few of the monitoring to go into
all the alphabet soup but a few examples
that specifically rate to the relate to
the importation of foreign workers they
involve both either or both of two ways
of approaching one is limiting the
number of people coming in who aren't
here already but also not renewing or
reviewing the status of supposedly
temporary workers who are already here
and let me just give a few quick
examples there's something called the
h-2b visa this is not the h-1b you would
have heard of I'll talk about that
briefly with h-2b it's for less skilled
seasonal work that's not in agriculture
most of these people are landscapers
they work in forestry amusement parks
there's no reason for having this visa
at all but I'll have that debate later
for now this has to be put on ice tens
of thousands of additional people from
abroad perfectly normal people their
workers listen they're not evil they're
not rapists they're just regular folks
but when we have 30 plus million people
looking for work the idea that these
jobs that Americans do because in every
one of the major categories
of people that are admitted under this
h-2b visa half or more in some cases 90%
of the people who do them are American
native-born Americans so this h-2b visa
should be put on ice the another example
is the h-1b visa this is one that's more
familiar it's usually used by tech
companies although there are some others
some physical therapists and other
people sometimes use it it's mainly used
by tech companies to import routine
people of relatively modest skills to do
routine computer work it's essentially
and I'm old I'm not really this isn't
really an exaggeration it's essentially
a white-collar force aero program a farm
worker type guest worker program but for
white collar workers working in cubicles
and it's used explicitly and lawfully to
replace American workers Disney you may
recall it was a front page story at the
Times about a few years back Disney used
this visa to replace American workers
they fired all their American IT staff
replaced them with these h-1b workers
and then forced the Americans to train
their replacements who frankly didn't
really know what they were doing this is
and this is not the only example
hundreds of companies have used it this
way it's and it's again a program that I
think should be gotten rid of altogether
and I'm willing to have that debate in a
year or two about whether we should have
this at all but for now putting it on
ice seems to me imperative because the
economic crisis that we're facing isn't
just people who are working at Starbucks
who have been impacted but white-collar
workers as well couple more categories
there's something on the optional
practical training program sounds kind
of wonky and narrow and yet it's one of
the largest guest worker programs in the
country
it is elite it's based on a legal
fiction where foreign students not
immigrants who happen to go to college
but students who are foreigners were
given a visa to come to study here after
they graduate our can
in you to masquerade as students but our
given work permits and for certain
categories of jobs they can stay in this
false status basically of pretending to
be students but actually being workers
from three years they pay no payroll tax
no Social Security tax no Medicare tax
no unemployment tax their employers
don't pay those taxes either and so they
are preferred lock you have for five
minutes
I hope thank you so again this is a
program that I think should just be
abolished altogether but you know we're
looking at short-term temporary prudent
measures it makes perfect sense to not
enroll people in this program once they
graduate because each year tens of
thousands of foreign students graduate
and sign up for this opt program is kind
of a way to bridge them to eventually
getting your green card halting signups
for this program again a common sense I
would admit I would submit imperative
short-term measure that we can revisit
next year or the year after and just the
last specific point I wanted to bring up
is something I hadn't really thought of
until I spoke to one of my analysts used
to be a visa officer and it makes sense
a lot of the categories either for green
cards no words permanent residents or
for these supposedly temporary work
visas require some kind of certification
that the employer can't find workers for
this spot can't find Americans for the
spot and therefore they get the green
light to bring in a foreign worker well
all of those labor certifications were
done in a completely different economy
the world changed
about a month and a half ago and so
let's see again as an as a measure of
prudence every one of those labor
certifications they're called needs to
be cancelled and Reese
mitad maybe some people still will be
able to make a case that Americans they
can't find Americans for certain jobs I
don't know um probably not but in any
case that should have to be redone
because circumstances have fundamentally
changed from when those applications
several months ago at least were
submitted so those are some of the
specific examples there's a lot more
tightening up an immigration I think
that needs to happen but you get the
idea there will be a time like I said
for a more fundamental debate over the
long-term direction of immigration
policy but that's something that's gonna
have to be done through Congress
you know ultimately you know the
legislature is supposed to be
legislating not just on immigration but
on everything else it's not clear that
Congress is capable of doing that right
now but that's where the more elementary
long-term changes in immigration policy
have to happen but the kinds of things
I've pointed out here are administrative
measures the president has the authority
to do the kind of temporary Prudential
restrictions on immigration that I I
think are it's hard to argue in my
opinion that they're not needed the
whole reason for the lockdowns that
we've been going through over the past
couple of months was for us as Americans
to do what was needed to protect our
fellow citizens especially the most
vulnerable from the ravages of this
virus because most of us on this on this
event I mean I don't want to ask
anybody's age but for the most part
probably there wasn't that much chance
we were gonna get sick the reason we did
all of this was to protect the elderly
protect the immunocompromised etc to
protect our vulnerable fellow citizens
as the economy reboots prudent steps
related to immigration have to be follow
the same tack words one minute Rahman
in other words we need to do what we can
to ensure that our fellow countrymen
especially the most vulnerable are the
first people in line to be hired or
rehired as we reboot the economy thank
you okay you you left about a half a
minute there mark but we don't have any
any purchase of transfer of time to the
other side so you you lost that half
minute Brian a Kaplan is a professor of
economics at George Mason University and
author of the graphic book open borders
the science and ethics of immigration
take it away Brian so I deleted
immigration many times before but today
there is a new and gripping argument
against immigration almost anyone can
see the force of it coronavirus
originated in China migration product
here and suddenly life is terrible
dogmatic libertarians can keep droning
on about Liberty but everyone else now
plainly sees that strict immigration
controls could have stopped this plague
and only strict immigration controls can
stop the plagues of the future this
argument sounds so right what could
possibly be wrong with it
I'll let's start by backing up before
the coronavirus did we have anything
close to open borders of course not
mark himself has conceded this point in
Prior debates under open borders the US
could easily have tens of millions of
immigrants annually a conservative
estimate says that our borders are
normally 95 percent closed I say some
more like 98 percent closed so what even
with our borders 98 percent closed the
virus still had no trouble spreading
here on a massive scale once a few sick
people enter your country it spreads far
and wide the same is true all over the
world the United Kingdom is an island
nation but it is the second highest body
count on earth so it seems like we
couldn't have solved our problem with
moderate further restrictions we need to
virtually end immigration altogether but
would that be enough no way he would
also have to virtually add international
tourism to
note that doesn't just mean keeping
foreign tourists out
it also means keeping domestic tourists
in or at least you have to tell your own
citizens if you leave you can't come
back the upshot you know cutting
immigration down to Japanese levels
would do very little documentation
instead it looks like you would have to
approach North Korea's policy of no one
gets in or out alive now at this point
you might be wondering well couldn't we
allow tourism but simply require a
strict supervised two-week quarantine
for all international travelers indeed
you could sadly this is so burdensome it
would practically eliminate
international tourism people would take
one or two international trips per
lifetime perhaps spending two weeks in
quarantine arrival and return but that's
about it
the benefit of tourism is too modest to
offset weeks of confinement but now we
reach the trillion-dollar question what
would be enough to offset weeks of
confinement the indubitable answer is
the opportunity to permanently emigrate
if you're already willing to leave your
country of birth to build a new life for
yourself two weeks of quarantine only
modestly increases the cost even
seasonal migrants would endure
quarantine they might lose a month of
time on a round-trip but US agricultural
wages are five times as high as they are
in Mexico the punchline then is that if
you are mortally afraid of contagion
what you need to stop is not immigration
but tourism which is by the way the
opposite of what it's like that happened
because we have long been ruled by in
numerous hysterical demagogues an
immigration policy of open borders
combine the two week quarantine would in
my view be an immense improvement over
the status quo I say that would move the
border from 98 percent closed to 95
percent open it can change and where
your sole objection immigration this is
the policy you should favor I know of
course the people of a long list of
other objections immigration indeed as
far as I recall this is my first debate
with mark I even mentioned contagion
instead mark primarily relies on
cultural objections in the past he has
while downplaying immigrations economic
benefits which makes me wonder has the
present crisis shed any new light on our
earlier disagreements the answer yes on
both counts a culturally the crisis has
shown that Americans have a lot to learn
from other cultures our way of handling
contagion has been clumsy at best maybe
we should have learned from Singapore
and South Korea maybe we should have
learned from Iceland and Sweden when
Americans definitely shouldn't do is
look in the mirror and admire our
wonderfully functional culture we're not
the worst on earth but now is a fine
time to embrace it curious cosmopolitan
perspective they got lessons lesson of
the crisis is truly clear-cut since
mid-march the greatest economy in human
history has been in shutdown or lockdown
our standard of living has crashed and
unemployment is near the level the Great
Depression why because we have
temporarily unknown the right of free
migration within the United States let
me repeat that our standard of living
has crashed because we have temporarily
annulled the right of free migration
within the United States Americans are
no longer able to work and shop where
they like the result is not a minor
inconvenience but disaster we are
suddenly stuck in a post-apocalyptic
movie
I detest diaper believe but this my
friends is no I / believe what would we
think however if this economic shutdown
had existed for all of living memory
we'd probably be content with the only
life we've ever known we only know what
we're missing because until very
recently we had it and we all look
forward to a future where we can restore
free migration within the United States
and regain its immense benefits
what does this have to do with
immigration but to quote obi-wan Kenobi
more than you can possibly imagine in
normal times current immigration law
keeps the whole world on permanent
lockdown while people can usually move
freely within the countries of the birth
of their birth government strictly
regulate international mobility this
regulation preps billions of people in
unproductive backwaters of the global
economy current policies don't just
needlessly impoverish all the would-be
immigrants eager to build better lives
for themselves they also impoverished
their billions of customers the secrets
of mass consumption is mass production
this is the most fundamental lesson of
economics when you shut down the
restaurant industry as we have you don't
just hurt waiters and dine and chefs you
hurt diners when you shut down
immigration you don't just her
immigrants you hurt all the natives who
would have purchased the fruits of
immigrant labor is the harm of ongoing
immigration restriction really
comparable to the harm of the
coronavirus lockdown definitely the
highest estimates of the fall and US GDP
are about 30% and that combines the
effects of the virus and the policy
response estimates of the total damage
of immigration restrictions in contrast
are typically around 50% of global GDP
in both cases
trakone Ian's restrictions on freedom of
movement strangle production even the
most ardent fans of the coronavirus
lockdown do not deny how much the
policies have depressed our standard of
living and our quality of life even the
fans of immigration in contrast rarely
realize how much the immigration
lockdown deprives humanity year after
year
how come almost everyone sees the former
cost the coronavirus lock down cost yet
almost no one sees the latter the
immigration lock down cost
because it's much easier for human
beings to miss wonderful things they
used to have than it is to miss
wonderful things they've yet to
experience
can we really compare the coronavirus
lockdown to the ongoing immigration
lockdown we can and we should the
coronavirus lockdown is only temporary
and delivers a semi plausible benefit
I'm against this lockdown but maybe I'm
wrong the ongoing immigration lockdown
in contrast has gone on for about a
century and delivers benefits so dubious
even their fans struggled to articulate
or quantify them and when we
sympathetically examine economic fiscal
cultural and political objections
immigration they turn out to be either
flat wrong or greatly overstated if you
want details try my new open borders the
science and ethics of immigration but
here's the quick version one economic
image xions immigration are totally
wrong headed to repeat the secret of
mass consumption is mass production and
immigration restrictions strangle
production by trapping human talent in
low creativity countries a Mexican
farmer grows far more food here that he
can grow back in Mexico not convinced
how productive would you be in Mexico
now Marc is this argument that
unemployment is really high and
therefore we need to keep immigrants out
this is a standard response during
almost every to every economic downturn
it was the standard response during the
Great Depression you may have heard
about farmers being paid to destroy food
during the Great Depression the
slaughter pigs that are fed to no one to
tear up so to Europe feels the food to
not be delivered to consumers and you
may have wondered what was the point of
all this the point of all this is to
save jobs during a time when collect
production has collapsed so this is the
wrong way of looking at any economy
you've got to focus on production what
they were doing there was just reducing
the production of any kind during a time
when people are going hungry when the
situations desperate
when things are doing very badly you
still need to remember the fundamental
principle namely get production back up
I'm going to talk about this more when
my rebuttal but Mark's reaction is
indeed the normal one during any
economic downturn is to say well right
now we've got a lot of unemployment
let's try to figure out a way to keep
production down five minutes and that is
not the right way of looking at it right
that is a way which has a lot of
superficial appeal when you really step
back you see this is madness this is the
act of short-sighted people who forget
the whole point of economy is to create
wealth back to fiscal objections to
immigration are flimsy despite the
existence of the welfare state which
libertarians always bring up in these
situations boring a political number
crunchers conclude that even low-skilled
immigrants are a net fiscal positive for
natives as long as they arrive when
they're young but you don't have to take
my word for it if you'd like looking at
numbers try Chapter 7 of the 2017 report
from the National Academy of Sciences if
you're reading this you can get the link
and go right to it
three cultural objections to immigration
are weak insofar as we can even measure
them almost all second-generation
immigrants speak fluent English
immigrants crime rates are lower than
natives an advanced this will work on
the effects of nations ancestry and
average IQ still imply massive gains of
immigration in a previous debate i asked
marco korean why he chooses to live in
the capital area one of the highest
immigration regions of america I kind of
expected mark to say something like it's
hell but I'm sacrificing my well-being
for the rest of America doesn't have to
endure the same fate but if I recall
correctly merger shrugged it's
complicated I suppose it is complicated
but I can't understand why you would
lead a political crusade against
anything complicated when the world is
still packed with stuff that's blatantly
bad for political objections finally
look minor at best in the US the
foreign-born are unfortunately more
economically more socially conservative
and economically liberal but there was
this modest
even immigrants to eligible vote have
low turnout and they're similar
descendants assimilate to mainstream
American culture it's not a big deal and
even if you disagree why not welcome
immigrants to live and work but not fit
I know there's a lot of information a
short space I'm happy to expand on any
of these topics in the Q&A but I
predictably stand by the inclusion of my
book immigration restriction is a
solution in search of a problem
people don't really know why they wanna
restrict immigration they just know what
they do which of course is why mark is
arguing for immigration restriction now
that unemployment is high you'll know he
was not doing so back not saying the
opposite was low he is a broken record
even at my book is thoroughly wrong
though the current crisis provides no
bonus argument in favor of numeration
restriction tourism including American
travel abroad may be a problem but we
can safely met all willing immigrants
with a suitable quarantine and such a
quarantine would do little to discourage
immigration because the gains are
astronomical
last point if you fear a world or
American citizens in the name of disease
prevention lose their basic freedom to
travel abroad I share your fear but when
you cherish this freedom
please remember the vast majority of the
world's population has lacked this
freedom for about a century even the
world's poorest people can scrape
together the money to get here what most
will never get is the government
paperwork that allows them to live and
work in peace our shutdown will end in
the foreseeable future the world
shutdown will endure until we see it for
the needless cruelty it is thank you
okay well are you will you gave up a
minute and 20 seconds so there you go
you you kid mark went better Brian
mark you have five minutes for a
rebuttal
take it away mark well let me start by
pointing out to some degree we're kind
of talking past each other at least
initially because I'm not really making
an argument with regard to pandemic I
think Brian is right that I'm
actually would go further than Brian I
don't think there's any practical way to
genuinely hermetically seal against
viruses like this this is going to
happen again and again and again
hopefully we'll be better prepared this
time it was different in the old days it
reminded me his comments reminded me of
the the speech from Richard ii the the
one this england where he says this
fortress built by nature for herself
against infection in the hand of war
because england was an island and it did
although even then england suffered from
the bubonic plague quite significantly
as did europe but i think be you know
the basic take away here from brian's
comments is that even in today's
conditions we should have unlimited
immigration in other words the 14 day
quarantine thing is something he's
willing to concede that's nice but it's
still unlimited immigration in
conditions where we have great
depression levels of unemployment if you
don't like trump or if you do like drop
you're gonna get a lot more of that
you're gonna wish you had Trump and York
Times well have strange new respect for
Trump given whatever the political
consequences would be after we
instituted a situation of open borders
under today's conditions so if for
nothing else
political prudence suggests responding
to the concerns of the public but my
point is that the immediate emergency we
face does in fact call for limits on the
number of new people allowed to come and
move and work in the United States you
know it's not entirely caused by the
state Brian's point that the lockdown is
something the government did the
government partly did it but the
government was a lagging indicator
people already stopped going to
restaurants and movies and what-have-you
because of fear of the virus that's why
regardless of what governors do as far
as we allowing businesses to reopen
people aren't this is not gonna just
bounce right back
this happened for organic reasons not
simply the decree of the state but
Brian's basic point is that everyone in
the world should have the right to move
here I mean this is what it boils down
to this is always what the debate
between libertarians and immigration
restriction astound is two different
points of view
Brian believes that everyone in the
world has the right to move here with
certain conditions we might impose in a
very limited way my perspective and
frankly honestly on anyone you've asked
on the street is that no one has the
right to move here except under
conditions that we set now
Brian's scenario could lead to low
immigration you could say everyone is a
right to move here but you have so many
conditions and exceptions that the
numbers aren't that high doesn't work
that way of course the reverse is also
true you could say that no one has a
right to move here is a privilege that
the self-governing American people
through their elected representatives
confer on you as a non-member but still
have extremely high levels of
immigration like we did until this virus
and like a lot of people in both parties
actually want to the gang of eight bill
you may recall double would have doubled
immigration and doubled guest worker
admissions but the but the principle the
basic principle is everyone gets to come
in others the American people have no
right there for one minute by minute guy
right that's the distinction do the
America that's the question do the
American people have the right to decide
how many people move into their country
or not that's I mean to get right down
to it that's what we're talking about
brian says no that the American people
through their democratic processes
through their elected representatives
are not allowed to decide how many
people get to move here and my
contention is I embrace democratic
self-governance the American people have
a right of self-determination and
through their
democratic process have the right to
decide who gets to move here how many
people and what the conditions are now
we can debate what those numbers should
be what the condition should be who
should be pushing and how we enforce the
law but the bedrock principle from my
perspective has to be the American
people have a right to
self-determination and Brian denies that
right thank you mock Brian
five minute rebuttal I thank you very
much so I am very sorry how come I'm not
appearing on the screen let's don't
worry don't worry don't worry don't
worry okay so I am extremely gratified
that mark is not making the argument
that almost every man on the street
would make which is that the reason why
we have this horrible problem is that we
were too easy on letting a bunch of
foreigners in and they came and spread a
bunch of disease and got a sick and the
thing to do is to first of all recognize
the problem was that we left them in the
first place and second I'll keep the mat
in the future you'll mark whether like
I'm delighted actually the mark is not
making this argument my whole picture
was that mark would be saying this this
thing which is very popular right now
also I congratulate mark for not
agreeing with the man on the street this
time but the man on the street in middle
east view makes very little sense of
course it's the one that politicians are
pandering to so I mean I'm glad that
mark is willing to say that it does not
make sense to say we're going to keep
out immigration the immigrants because
they will spread disease if we just had
a more restrictive policy we'd be having
less disease so anyway that's great that
mark doesn't say that because that
argument is wrong and doesn't make a lot
of sense I hope that mark makes an
effort to tell his supporters that this
argument is incorrect because they're
not gonna believe it if I say it but if
mark tells them I think they will
actually believe him and so you know
like often I will say that if there is
an argument that I don't that it
supports my view that I think is wrong I
go when I tell my friends stop making
the argument the arguments wrong we have
to fix the argument truth first and I
would be very happy if Mark would go and
do the same and spread the word among
opponents of immigration that the fear
of contagion is not a good reason to
stop now to focus on Mark's argument
let's just go back
as I said during every major recession
or depression there are voices like mark
saying we've got to figure out a way to
protect jobs right and the logic of this
does go down to the Great Depression
route of trying to restrict production
in the hopes that if say you go and
destroy a whole lot of foreign
production this will make more jobs for
farmers in the hopes that if you go and
say we're going to keep out foreign
imports that this is going to create
jobs for people and import competing
industries and so on these policies have
a very bad track record right and again
it's not so surprising why because
Mark's problem is that he's not focusing
at all in production when mark says the
fundamental disagreement between
restriction Asst and advocates of open
borders is this concern for the nation I
say it's actually comes down to the
basic economics when you look at an
economy do you look at it as a
redistributed system of giving people a
job or do you look at as a system for
production for a mission world
libertarian view is it's there to enrich
the world and once you take that
perspective taking a look at recession
saying what can we do in order to go and
protect people's jobs it's just the
wrong way of looking at it's like what
can we do to get production back up all
right now Mark was going over a lot of
different arcane integration categories
in the case of agriculture it really is
a problem right now that a lot of
American crops are not likely to be
picked because apparently even according
to mark for no good reason we are
keeping out seasonal workers on now any
long ago debate mark disagreed with and
I second in his disagreement with the
argument of the jobs that Americans will
not do mark very correctly said we'll
make the wages high enough and Americans
will do them I said but there is a
correct and improved version of this
argument and this is jobs that won't be
done at all if only Americans can do
them there are a lot of crops that
simply will not be picked if you have to
pay Americans wages and so that is food
that will not be ending up in our
grocery stores at a time where as you
may have noticed a lot of shelves were
empty with a lot of products that
ordinarily would have been there let's
see and of course the same goes for many
of the industries that Mark is picking
on so Disney right Disney is really
suffering they've lost nearly so they're
there they're down about a billion
dollars
right at this point to be kicking them
by going and saying we've got to go and
disrupt the whole business model to make
them create jobs for Americans one man
putteth at a time when there is minimal
tourism anyway again you miss writers
think you even mark should be worried
about the possibility that you wind up
giving putting one last kick into the
head of business and so rather than
creating jobs by saying they have to
hire Americans you just wind up sending
the businesses into the garbage can
again there are a lot of retailers as
well that seem like they may just
forgive all clothes rather rather than
ever open oh let's see so oh yes let me
just make one last point I noticed that
mark did not say anything about letting
in more health care workers this is
really important to do right now it
would be really great to let in more
health care workers in to the United
States but by this laundry table well we
got to go and create jobs for people and
protect them rather than thinking of the
point of a job is to provide a useful
service we probably are going to keep
them out a shame
okay well that concludes the the first
part of the evening and we now go to the
Q&A we've had a number of interesting
questions coming in let me just exercise
moderators prerogative to remind Brian
and certainly my NIC and then inform
mark that there are a lot of
libertarians who who disagree with Brian
and that in fact there's a fair amount
of divisive opinion among libertarians
with respect to the immigration question
but that aside which is not so important
I first want to ask Brian and ask mark
do you want to put a question to mark
Brian marked you one could put a
question to Brian or do you want to wait
for the audience questions either one of
you I'm mark Brian let's have the
audience give their questions I mean
that's more important Brian and I have
done this a lot we've we know each
other's answers and questions well which
of course of course you want it there
are people you guys are just not that
popular mark a lot of people out there
who haven't heard this this act that you
guys have taken on the road so you could
ask questions Brian do you want a smart
question or do you want it
absolutely because I don't know what
mark is gonna say about this okay okay
okay mark so should we reopen the
borders to Taurus right now today
gradually slowly I mean you said no this
is this is the point you were making
about the you know you were glad I
wasn't making the argument that
immigrants are diseased or whatever it
is I'm not actually sure who's made that
argument that I mean clearly flights
continued from Wuhan to the west coast
even after the chai calms knew if the
virus could be transferred from one
person to the next so that was actually
outrageous and should not have been
allowed so controls on travel controls
on tourism I think are appropriate as a
Prudential short-term measure it doesn't
shape immigration what if let whatever's
in the out and what's that what
difference does it make now
right here so why not reopen and let
your respect you I mean I'm okay for
reopening but I'm early opening in
general in a graduated prudent cautious
way the airline's first of all it has to
be somebody who wants to come the
airlines have to take you know various
security steps that sort of thing but
I'm I'm okay with that
again if it's done in a deliberate
prudent planned out fashion not just
okay you know everything's back to
normal which is not the way we're
opening any other businesses either a
mark you want a wave wave a quick wave
you right to ask them Brian a question
and but of course you can exercise your
prerogative at any time during the
during the QA we are we're getting a
couple of interesting questions for mark
coming in and I've heard this point made
before that that there you answer the
question about tourists and then there's
another question about a related
challenge about new entrants into the
population you questions you you'd said
mark that that we should take it to a
vote as to whether we get new entrants
of the population that the entire
population should vote on whether some
employer in Massachusetts or in New York
City accepts an immigrant it should be
the right of the people that's that's
what the question is summarized it seems
to be your position correct yeah I mean
be able to vote on this and though so
whatever so if you want to hire an
immigrant then to assist you on your
research so maybe somebody from Armenia
then then it should be the right of the
population to the referendum to vote on
whether you can honor that person that's
not what I mean I know I did the
referendum it's a terrible way to run
government
okay bomb my present is that people set
up the rules within which the you know
within which all these things operate
their ways if they want to restrict it
to 250 thousand a year so be it whatever
it is
to our elected representatives our
representatives I'm a Republican not a
not a fan of direct democracy okay fair
enough and that summarize the view and
the challenge or more that's
if you could and then then the question
is aren't there new entrants on a
continuing basis from tourism should
there be a limit on that and then the
other challenge that I know is classic
but that this president probably got
from wall to block how about those new
entrants that are better newborns
O'Brien has got four kids all of those
people streaming in and a lot of
foreigners as you know farm boy to have
a lot of kids should there be the
Congress and the sender and the
president dictating how many new engines
can come from newborns by the same logic
that's the challenge no definitely not
which is that frankly I mean my you know
I'm not I see myself more as a
conservative than a libertarian but I am
sympathetic to libertarianism in one
country to borrow from to adapt somebody
else's a phrase on this in other words
within the United States not the
government's building business tell
anybody how many kids they have I have
three kids he's got for it please that
more but it's the Communist Cummins
business to tell you in effect how many
immigrants you can hire for your you're
not completely different things okay
well they're different they're category
as a category all right do you want to
come in on that Brian or should I get to
those doing it yeah I mean of course
it's not really category or it's just
that mark considers the right to have as
many kids as you want to something that
should be above democracy where's the
right to move is to something it should
be up to democracy as to why exactly
there's that difference I don't know I
mean when Marcos and presents his
position it makes it sound like I'm a
terrible leadest who's depriving the
people of their choice and he is a good
guy who is letting the people decide
what to do right but when it comes to
how about know how many kids you have
then suddenly it's not up to should not
be up to the people it should be up to
the individual I say should be up to the
individual both case it says of course
and the last person would ever make mark
high on immigrants and the last person
that would ever make him socialize with
immigrants and as I said I wouldn't make
him live in a city that has a lot of
immigrants although he has chosen to
live at least Mira can't remember marks
address but whether it's decent done
don't die yeah I wouldn't wouldn't dream
my apologies yeah
this isn't
immigrants is people this is always a
mistake that and there are in fact some
restrictions you just don't like far
there's no question about that but this
bait this issue is not about immigrants
as people it's about immigration policy
now I'm not gonna go and say look some
of my best friends are immigrants
although honestly I spoke Armenian
before I spoke English the church where
I'm actually an essential employee and
have been on the altar every week during
this lockdown everywhere every other
person on that altar is an immigrant so
you know this idea that somehow being
for a more limited federal immigration
program because that's what it is it's a
government program like farm subsidies
or SBA loans in and so we can be bigger
or going to be smaller being in favor of
a smaller federal government immigration
program has nothing to do with the moral
worth or the individual personality or
qualities or evidence immigrants or
people just like anybody else some are
good some are bad some are a little bit
of each just like all the rest of us
it's about government policy and what we
as a people citizens of a nation who
have an obligation to each other which
Trump's the obligation we have to
foreigners what we decide to do
collectively about and many new people
into our club and it's our right to do
that and then we can debate about how
best to do that but the first principle
has to be that we get to decide as a
people who moves here and who does huh
question for Brian a thank you Mark
Cristiano Brian could you put on your
crystal ball and predict what is likely
to happen if indeed open borders were
declared tomorrow there is of course
questions coming in about concerns that
at a 20% plus unemployment rate and the
likelihood that the unemployment rate is
going to be slow to come down that there
could be a lot of pain at this point
Fordham for
domestically based workers if open
borders were imposed right now so what
is what in your view is likely to
wouldn't be likely to happen if open
boys would declare tomorrow so we
actually have pretty good data about
this from the open borders period
although it's true even today namely
that when economic conditions are good
more people want to immigrate when
economic conditions are bad fewer people
want to immigrate and when economic
conditions are terrible people do tend
to stay home you can actually see this
in the European Union where they got
open borders within the Union and you'll
notice that workers move very heavily to
the countries with low unemployment
rates and very rarely move the countries
high unemployment rates so you know I
say that to large extent that problem
does tend to take care of itself
although here's the thing if people were
worried that the open borders wouldn't
last it was just a brief window that I
think there are a lot of people would
come no matter how desperate conditions
are just to get in before they get close
again so it really does depend upon the
exact hypothetical but again when people
are worrying about the suffering of
American workers
remember the flip side of this is the
suffering of American consumers right so
if you sit around saying okay how can we
go and protect jobs for workers you were
simultaneously saying let's go and screw
over consumers and not worry about
production but you can't have it both
ways that you're going and trying to
keep workers out of the labor market
you are also thereby keeping Goods out
of stores right now people like to
forget this but again the secret of mass
consumption is mass production if you
could cut down on production by reducing
employment you are cutting down on the
standard of living right this is
standard the standard short-sighted
impulsive thing to do during difficult
times but we must resist this impulse
even during hard times we need to focus
on getting production back up and
actually since this is very much a
supply driven recession rather than
demand driven one the case is even
clearer we've got to get production back
up you've got to get goods back in
stores and that means workers right and
notice particular there are a lot of
Americans who were too scared to work
there are a lot of foreigners that would
be happy to assume the risk so keep that
in mind as well right now you like in
New York City at least a few weeks ago
the US was paying $10,000 for a week for
nurses for other perks the country to go
there if we could have had open
medical workers we could have gotten a
lot of other medical workers in there
and had much greater availability but of
course that was not done yes I guess if
I had to slip in one more last remark
how about hey Mark
we have temporary visas for health
workers right now please
okay Brian as a matter of fact somebody
read your mind and that question came in
from our audience but please hold on
that question because in terms of
protocol
I want mark to comment on the answer you
just gave yeah to that prior question go
ahead Thank You gene because this issue
of what would happen if we opened the
borders let's even take it apart from
the current emergency circumstances
because of the pandemic the the Brian
touted the estimate that you know global
GDP would increase by half again or
toward a double or whatever it is
trillions of dollars of increased
production it's ludicrous on its face
and the reason is the assumptions behind
that estimate have to be examined this
is what people who aren't familiar with
this sort of thing have learned about
all of this modeling kovat nonsense that
if you put in garbage of some since you
get in garbage results and this
trillions of dollars of increased output
is based on the assumption that
virtually every human being from the
third world moves to the developed world
five billion people at least would move
to the United States Europe and Japan
that would be roughly if you think about
it maybe two billion people from the
third world move to the United States
the institutions that create the greater
productivity that we enjoy would not
survive under those circumstances it is
an absurd situation or it's an absurd
assumption to say that open borders
would result in massively increased
output and look we're not just biessing
in a sophomore college dorm rooms we're
talking about actual policy and actual
policy actual governance has to consider
what would actually happen open borders
would lead to political revolution
and so if you want more immigration you
know just as a just as a hint I mean
just as a tip you want to go you want an
incremental approach which is what
basically the Democratic Party and much
of the Republican Party the corporate
elements of it are pushing for they're
not oh they're not coming out and saying
they're for open borders that's true
they would keep an arm's distance from
Brian but they are the essentially the
Mensheviks to Brian's bolsheviks and I
don't mean this in a derogatory follow
this sort of throguh Tory how can you
avoid the but my point is their
incremental lists they want to achieve
the same thing Brian does but they want
to boil the Frog slowly so it doesn't
jump out my point is the Frog is gonna
want to jump out if you turn the heat up
yeah yeah yeah because because Mark
actually brought up a new issue having
to do with the 50% rising GDP I want I
want to have another round on that Oh
would you respond to the challenge about
the estimates of the GDP effect and
whatever else you want to say in terms
of what Brian what Mark just said
go ahead Brian yeah sure first of all I
really hope that mark is right that the
whole Democratic Party and the corporate
wing the Republican Party is secretly
with me or they're with me in spirit or
somehow they're trying to pave the way
for what I'm talking about
I've actually talked to a Larry large
number of American Democrats and
corporate Republicans and they very
rarely see eye to eye with me
they almost totally almost all them
totally disagree so this is really just
a strange conspiracy theory that Mark is
somehow fond of conspiracy all right now
inter in terms of the of the model so I
only had a head about 30 seconds to talk
about it the models that Mark is talking
about when he when he says that seem
like you need to look into them the
people that develop them
have looked into them I just didn't have
time to go into the details now when I
talked about say doubling the production
of the world with open borders I don't
mean that would happen tomorrow right I
do I mean that is they look at a
reasonable predict
the long-run effects well think about it
this way if we had kept open borders if
we had not when it ought to shut down
immigration starting in 1921 and then 24
this is the world that we would be in
now a much better world with much higher
production yes so if you let in a
billion people overnight I agree that
it's going to lead to very drastic
consequences you probably couldn't even
thrive in the streets there'd be so many
people there fortunately that's not
actually what happens when you go and
open borders because the normal thing
that happens you can go and read Paul
Colliers excellent book the idea yes but
no so that's just against prints begin
anyway so I'm gonna go these book is
about Liberty talks about the Osprey
dynamics so I mean Paul yeah Paul
Collier who is also very skeptical of
immigration she says look the way that
immigration usually works that star cell
flow and then it snowballs and that's
right and that's why open borders is a
fine policy because when you first open
a border you get a modest amount of
immigration and then grows and grows and
grows which means that you can absorb it
at a reasonable level and then you can
grow a lot of Norma's amount over time
but it does take a long time and we
interest to get an idea of like is it
really scary to bring two billion
America or two billion more people year
over a century it's not scary at all the
u.s. now is about a hundred times the
population that had and when it first
was formed basically each century we're
getting about in chrome increased about
tenfold some of that from normal
population growth but a lot of it from
immigration if you if you increase the
population the u.s. 100 fold in 1789
would be a disaster do it over two
centuries and it's totally fine people
barely even realized there was there was
a difference except that things no
there's a lot more people enjoying a
much better life I mean if I could just
add one asterisk I don't want to I want
people to be able to get the questions
in but we've never had open borders
because in the past
putting aside the legal restrictions
that existed even in the 17th century
against coppers immigrating for instance
that sort of thing so there are many
immigration restrictions literally from
the foundation of the Massachusetts Bay
Colony
but put that aside with primitive
transportation and communications
technology the oceans were our
immigration limits that is how we
limited immigration and the reason
immigration and that
to be legislatively restricted
statutorily restricted starting in the
20s was precisely because communications
and transportation had become so cheap
that the oceans no longer served the
purpose as Shakespeare wrote you know
served in the office of a wall or as a
moat protective once that once the world
shrinks the only way you limit the way
you have to move to limiting immigration
is through statute rather than relying
on IV muk muk if then to follow up on
the point you just made if if Brian got
his way and open borders were declared
tomorrow then
how many people do you think would
migrate to the US over the next twelve
months I can't come up with a number but
it depends on several things let me say
one does every other developed country
have open borders well it's just the
u.s. if it's just us you could easily
end up with 10 million people moving
here in a period of the year
I mean that would not be that would be
in my opinion that would be a low
estimate but I don't know I mean I
haven't gained it out but yeah it could
easily be ten million people not now
with the virus situation in the economy
the way it is but start like January 1st
of 2021 they're clearly open the borders
you would have I think you'd get at
least 10 million people the gap is asked
people in 168 million people around the
world have told Gallup that they want to
move here that is that that's less than
3% of the US population right now so it
would be a not a huge increase
but anyway any further just mentioned
you want to make up this point Brian
know if you want to go you know let's go
to questions okay so another question
for mark which seems to pick up on what
Brian had called his keyhole solutions
mark a couple of things that are related
Brian asked about health care workers he
also raised the question as another
question here has about agricultural
workers letting them in and then the
keyhole solution that somebody proposed
was that there might be some kind of tax
imposed on employers who want to bring
in immigrants and then that money would
be allocated to augment the unemployment
insurance payments
that are being made to unemployed people
which as you know now are being
subsidized at 600 a week so that
actually unemployed people in many cases
of getting nine over nine hundred
dollars a weekend in compensation which
is actually giving them a disincentive
to work but again in health care
agriculture and then potentially
imposing some tax on employers who bring
in immigrants in order to to soften the
blow to domestic workers with any of
those things
yes matter to you yeah yeah let me I
mean the farming issues I'm glad Brian
brought that up too early yes and that's
an important one because I actually
improbable somebody on my side and
actually this is something I actually do
differ to some degree with a lot of
people on my side I'm actually okay with
the administration's facilitating the
entry of what they call each to a farm
workers these are people on farm worker
visas not because I think that's a good
idea but because in other words in
general but because the farmers do in
fact have the stuff in the ground
already and the adjustments that will be
necessary to wean them off the drug of
foreign labor take time so I'm actually
ok with the foreign farm workers being
admitted now what I'm most concerned
with sort of in the medium term is is
that it represents it underlines a
vulnerability that we have just as the
reliance on Chinese made pharmaceuticals
and the Chinese government's use of them
use of sort of withholding them using it
as a kind of weapon or attempted
coercion against us is a vulnerability
our reliance for our food supply at
least for a small part of our food
supply the vegetables and fruits not all
the rest of it most of our calories come
from crops harvested by machine but the
produce department comes from stuff
harvested lard not a largely by hand but
significant element of labor is involved
that is a vulnerability a very serious
vulnerability to food security and the
issue is not that you know
immigrant farm workers are sort of
tainting the food or whatever you
actually hear some fringy coops bringing
that up that's not the issue the issue
is farmers can't get this stuff out of
the ground without importing people from
other countries and so for doing that
right now is essential but what the
government needs to do going forward is
make it clear to farmers that that's not
going to be allowed to continue that the
price of importing this foreign labor is
going to increase 10 percent every year
and I would actually to follow on the
other part of the question you had
charged the farmers and the farm workers
payroll taxes they now do not pay
payroll taxes and clip and give the farm
workers back to payroll taxes as rebates
take the farmer portions invest it in
mechanization technology because it's
true that you're not going to have the
same number of Americans going out
picking cucumbers as there are foreign
workers doing it now what you can do is
move away from the medieval form of
labor arrangements that we have in the
fields now toward a more modern kind of
harvesting of fruits and vegetables and
that's something the government does
need to give a push to farmers to so
that you'll have instead of a hundred
people kneeling in the dirt
picking radishes by hand which is
literally the way it's done now you'll
have a machine which exists now in
Europe and Japan because they don't have
the same access to cheap Labor's we do
you know the Machine run by three people
harvesting ten times as much in half the
time
so for now imported farm workers I think
actually are essential this month next
month the month after but there has to
be a plan for weaning farmers off this
addiction to a labor that's imported
from abroad okay other related parts of
that question which maybe we could get
back to do you want to comment on that
friends at the time for the moment yes
except it's striking to me that for
culture mark finally has the
economically sensible view in part that
the point of farms is production and we
should not be focused on just creating
as many jobs as possible for Americans
this is a grid view this would be the
view that mark should have on all areas
of the economy all the time focus on
production not jobs the jobs take care
of themselves in a well-functioning
economy like the u.s. normally has is
production that's hard now when you talk
about foreign labor as an addiction this
is really just the same as saying that
I've got an addiction to gasoline or an
addiction to any other cheap convenient
thing we have I know you could go and we
Miura pians off their addiction to
machinery by going and putting a big tax
on that and then they'll do it in some
other way
you know the key point is that the
reason why we're doing this way is
because we have a resource and a
technology that is actually better
considering the cost and cost is the way
that central economies manage things not
with some kind of of buzz lightyear idea
of the highest technology's always the
best very often high technology is not a
good way of doing it often I will do
something by hand because the
technologically advanced way is actually
less convenient
similarly American farmers will hire
workers because the farm machinery sets
too expensive and it makes sense to do
it the cheaper way just as a final point
there gene it's not actually just the
immediate cost because there's a certain
is a hump that you have to pass when you
mechanize you have to change the whole
system of production including packing
including shipping etc and once you get
over that hump to a different situation
you actually will end up with higher
productivity on the part of the workers
it's just that there has to be an
incentive to do that
immigration removes that incentive and
what it does is it permits agriculture
to continue in what amounts to a kind of
medieval labor arrangement with people
as quasi serfs deep kneeling in the dirt
and picking stuff with their hands a
modern economy shouldn't be feeding
itself that way yeah getting back to
that then a related question I guess
mark we could pass over the other ones
but the estimate of over 10 million
people working illegally in this country
would you would you have the government
expel them well first of all it's the
the number of illegal immigrants is
probably 10 to 12 million the number who
are working is probably 7 to 8 million
because some of them are kids some of
them are old people's illegal workers
are like 7 or 8 million ok no again
prudence none of those people should be
here they not only broke administrative
rules they're all they virtually every
single one was engaged in criminal
activity they've ID theft perjury tax
fraud etc but given all of the decades
of a feckless immigration policy by the
other members if you will of Bryan's
beehive who don't realize that they are
essentially moving in the same or recoil
from admitting that they're calling for
the same thing as he is but are in fact
doing that my point is you've got that
many people it is imprudent and
disruptive to throw everybody out all at
once what we need to do is make it
harder for illegal immigrants to get
jobs harder to live a normal life so
that through attrition we shrink the
numbers and then after at some point we
come to a decision that we've done about
all as much as all we can let's legalize
everybody else rip off the band-aid I'm
actually for an amnesty at some point in
exchange for deep permanent cuts in
legal immigration
in other words clean up the mess of our
past immigration policy but going
forward with a different and newer
immigration policy and let me just put
in one last point because we are
rebooting our economy in effect I mean
our you know they talk about the ship of
state sort of the desktop of state was
turned off because it had a virus and
we're not rebooting it we've started it
again and what we should be doing in my
opinion is using for instance be
verified which is an online system for
people when they hire somebody and take
the Social Security and IRS information
they have to collect anyway to require
them to actually check online and see
whether that's whether the lying to them
or not that is the kind of step that you
take now we
can correct some of the distortions that
have developed in our economy over the
years which because we're rebooting the
system as it were coming from you Brian
know any comic also was fine
okay the they must go back to a
classical question which I guess reminds
us that not all libertarians have always
agreed with Brian the Milton Friedman
question who who held that the welfare
state is incompatible with unrestricted
immigration could you address that point
Brian uh sure
so logically speaking the argument makes
perfect sense it's theoretically
possible the welfare state is so is so
excessive that when we let immigrants in
we don't actually get these benefits and
furthermore I mean I I would say
probably Milton would say that if the
damage to American liberty is large
enough that it would be justified to go
and restrict these Liberty foreigners
and order twice out that slightly on
sale but again large enough now the
question is how do the numbers actually
turn out and I say when we go and look
at those numbers National Academy of
Sciences you'll see that Milton Friedman
is just plain wrong the American welfare
state is not so large to actually turn
immigration into a fiscal burden on
Americans in fact in even low-skilled
immigrants as long as they're young or a
net fiscal benefit in the modern United
States like how could that possibly be a
couple things are going on so first of
all a lot of government products or a
lot of government services are non
viable that means the cost doesn't
depend upon population and so you can
let an immigrant in charge of modest
taxes and he's still more spent more
than pays for himself
second of all immigrants tend to be
young rather they tend to be young which
end most of the wealth American welfare
state goes to the old now if that sounds
like a pyramid scheme it is not because
this basic finance tells you a debt
delayed is a lower debt if you can make
a debt if you pay it pay up stand the
same debt 50 years it is in fact a
smaller debt then you pay it right now
so in fact letting in more immigrants
does make the system more state more
sustainable not less and then finally
it's also true that a large large part
of the cost of immigrants is for
educating their kids often there
are in fact US citizens cuz they're born
here but the key thing to remember is
that if you have family of three natives
two native parents one dative kid u.s.
taxpayers pay for all three of their
education if you a family of tumour
parents and one kid u.s. taxpayers only
pay for one education so that's another
reason why immigrants are a great deal
on now there's just bring us back to
that question that Merck didn't like
about if you're against if government
should control immigration how not might
have fertility but again really it is
exactly the same issue so if it's
justified to say the welfare state is so
big we're gonna take away people's
freedom to migrate why is it justified
to say the welfare state is so big we're
gonna take away the right of for people
to have kids when they want to and
philosophically I would say it is the
same problem and in both cases I think
the reasonable answer is if it were
gonna be a total disaster then maybe it
would be okay to limit to limit that
freedom but let's make sure it would be
a total disaster before we start going
and doing something that crazy and when
we go and look at those numbers it's
just not there so yeah bright bright I
bought a bottom line bill he was wrong
okay look then what's wrong indeed cuz
he's deceased absolutely because he what
you were speaking of me about him in the
present tense because of course he's
always with us in terms of his arguments
which was great uh and now we go to the
final part of the evening a mark you can
of course obviously respond to what
Brian just said you have you five
minutes rebuttal take it away mark well
I mean I think I want to respond and
sort of make a more general point Brian
is saying that the restrictions on
foreigners moving here that the
limitation on their freedom that is he's
an egg is analogizing it or not
analogize he's equating it to the
decision of Americans to have kids in
other words that they should be the same
thing they should have both be
restricted by the state or neither the
problem is that this is this goes back
to the original fundamental disagreement
we have I think that Americans have a
moral responsibility to each other that
is greater than they have two farms that
the the United States
and the American people are a our nation
and innate the members of a nation the
citizens of a nation have
responsibilities to each other there are
different rules for those who are US as
opposed to those who are them and the US
and them is not a moral critique in the
sense that somehow foreigners are
inferior or defective or what-have-you
but the same rules do not apply to them
we met when the the preamble of
Constitution says we the people of the
United States that's not we the
residents who happen to be here in the
United States at this particular time
it's those of us who are citizens of the
United States and as a citizen you have
rights given to you by God which are
enshrined and protected in our
Constitution and our laws those rights
do not all apply in the same way to
foreigners coming here a foreigner has a
right to life just as an American does
he doesn't have a right to a life here
sovereignty the basic concept of
sovereignty is that the sovereign which
in our system is the American people
it's not the king it's not the Pope it's
not the Emperor it's the American people
through their elected representatives
get to decide who moves here and who
doesn't there are rules and privileges
that we enjoy that we are subject to
that foreigners are not and that is what
it boils that really want in principle
what it boils down to somebody who is
abroad in a low productivity country
which is low productivity not because of
anything we did it's simply because of
their lower level of cultural
development there whatever inheritance
is they have from their own history in
their own past it's just not a very
productive place they have no right to
move here that's their country we have
no right to move to their country and
you can call for higher levels of
immigration if you want
the only legitimate way in my opinion to
make that argument as part of democratic
discourse is to argue that the American
that the American people would benefit
and Brian does that sometimes but he's
trying to steal a base because
necessarily he would support the hope
the unlimited immigration of people from
abroad even if it were bad for Americans
in his conception and that's in my
opinion not that that's that's a value
question it's sort of a it's a you know
it's like a [ __ ] I mean in geometry you
know a basic theorem the definition of a
point a line in the plane you don't have
to justify those or prove those you take
those as given well you have to take as
given cool do you have your primary
responsibility to a poor one minute one
minute who is what what moral units are
you part of who is your responsibility
toward and that is that's not something
you can really you know game out and
debate and come to some kind of
empirical conclusion it's a value
question
I value my fellow citizens more than I
value foreigners doesn't mean foreigners
are subhuman or any sort of that
pre-modern concept where every tribe
called itself the human beings and
everybody else was not human beings I'm
a Christian I recognize that all of all
of us are children of God but I have a
greater responsibility to my own people
than I do to foreigners Brian does not
accept that concept if that's not a
wrong position it's just a different
position but if you start from one of
those two positions you end up at very
different places at the end of the day
thank you
I can never see is org thank you Mark
Brian five minutes of rebuttal of
concluding rebuttal yeah
all right so let's go back to the actual
resolution of the debate which is does
the coronavirus crisis actually enhance
the argument for restricting immigration
oh it straight into me is first of all
mark distances himself from the normal
argument that people on the street
actually make of course it's a little
hard to meet people on the street
anymore but on the phone the kinds of
things that my dad would say alright so
and again the normal argument that I
think a large majority of Americans
accept is that the reason why we got
this problem is because we were too
lacks and letting foreigners in they
came and they sickened us if we had been
stricter it wouldn't have happened and
if we don't want us to happen again we
gotta be stricter in the future right
mark doesn't actually seem to want to
make that argument which is great but I
think that by refusing to make that
argument he has really eliminated most
of the case that he could make for
further restrictions and immigration
always really left with is this
depression economics one but
unemployment is high we should go and
try to protect jobs without without any
real consideration of the effect on
production the harm that Willis will do
to businesses that are immigration
dependent and then he makes a few
exceptions well yeah okay agriculture
okay but there's knee on the other hand
he's still mad and I'm not quite sure
but he's got against his knee I love
Disneyland by the way it's a wonderful
place and if they but if they operate
with immigrants more power to them many
gay so remembering the resolution it's
about whether this current crisis
enhances the argument the mark has been
making for many many years and he
doesn't use he doesn't make the argument
that you would actually think would make
which is good because as I said is wrong
we couldn't actually keep we could not
actually get the virus out at a
reasonable cost by simply closing the
borders and again you have to eliminate
tourism including our right to travel
abroad so it's just crazy and even if
you're really worried about that should
focus on quarantines rather than
anything else and then again this
unemployment argument is just the usual
one that people shred out during every
recession where they keep their eye off
the ball of production and on this
distraction of employment which is a
terrible mistake
especially when stores have loss of
empty shelves I've been there I am
terrified now to go shopping not just
from getting sick but just to see what
has happened to my beloved grocery
stores and what has happened to them you
know like what consumer would what
it's very sad alright uh now on this
question of whether or not you have a
right to emigrate or not oh yeah I think
you do but again you could just as well
make my argument saying yes democracy
whatever it says is great but democracy
should vote for what I'm saying and
almost all my argument still go through
you'll notice that I really only switch
over to the moral arguments when the
moral argument comes up otherwise I'm
happy to focus on the actual expected
consequences let's see so there's one
thing I want people to keep in mind from
all this is that we actually learned
something about immigration from the
current shutdown as I said during the
current shutdown we are suffering
because Americans have been deprived of
their normal right to free migration
we're no longer able to live and shop
where we want which is terrible we have
lost an enormous amount because we can't
move around anymore this is a permanent
problem with the global economy we are
permanently losing these benefits
because there are a lot of gains of
letting people move from country to
country the same kinds of games you get
by able to go to your job or go to a
store where you watch there's someone in
a gate that's by being able to come to
you these are the games that we give up
in the global economy every day the
reason why we can easily believe that
we're having enormous losses right now
is that we remember how things used to
be the reason why mark is so much
trouble believing that things could be
dramatically better is that we haven't
seen these games they are foregone
rather than taken away and what I'm
saying is we really should focus on what
we are missing again if this lockdown
went on long enough eventually we would
forget that anything better was possible
and then there'd be someone like mark
saying oh this is all fantasy you can't
really improve that much it would be so
disruptive for institutions if people
could go and sit down at restaurants
what would happen to the grocery stores
all this kind of negative focus on
employment rather than a positive focus
on progress and production it has great
appeal box emotionally right and it's
the kind of thing that comes to people's
heads there's kind of and it's the kind
of thing that any good economics class
tries to beat out of the students so
thoroughly that it never comes back and
so let me try to beat it out of you
right now
let's say and yes one last point so mark
does not like the argument of keep out
immigrants because they're inferior
here's what I say that's the good
argument that's the argument that makes
sense if the immigrants really are
barbarians and they're going to come
here and run amok then I can understand
why people don't want them here that is
what the scurrilous members of the
Internet's who are hardcore opponents of
immigration do now mark I think mark
sincerely does not agree with those
people
the nicety mark doesn't really have any
good argument left all he's left with is
some discussion about how Americans are
different theoretically from foreigners
but he never really addresses the point
of the complaints that you have about
immigrants also apply just as well to
also apply just as well to Americans so
if you're worried about immigrants
taking jobs you'd be worried about
Americans taking jobs you're worried
about immigrants taking jobs you're
worried about more women working the
logic of this mark doesn't want to deal
with any I think the reason is that if
you really pursued it you would end up
at my view not this Thanks thank you
thank you Brian okay
oh well that concludes the arguments on
both sides Jane please open the final
vote and you are watching this on
livestream please cast your file vote
however we won't be announcing the
results until next Tuesday because
reason is going to release this on video
and audio this Friday and people will
have through the weekend and into Monday
to watch and cast their own final vote
the results will be announced again next
Tuesday thanks to you both Brian and
mark I want to remind you both of course
that you are alumni of the physical soul
forum brian has been at the physical
solar forum a couple of times
mark visit us visited us once we hope to
have you back I just learned before we
turn this on that Brian always looking
for new employment into diversified his
own skills wants to apply to be a
stand-up act at the Seoul forum Brian I
remind you that we are the Big Apple and
therefore I encourage you
- what to try out your act with the
Nerds at GM you the faculty and students
and we'll get some recommendations from
them how do you how do you get to the
sella forum practice practice practice
can I just say one thing I'm so happy to
see all of you I'm really happy to see
mark I just feel so lonely so distressed
by a terrible situation just to even see
a human being on a screen it's a big
improvement for me and honestly this is
what I said the same feeling and I have
whatever I need to do in order to this
country I'm glad to have you I'm glad to
see all of you you're seeing us another
country I want you here and if Americans
get their act together you'll be allowed
got on that note of love Brian and
market both come to love each other even
though they disagree profoundly about
certain issues and I hope to see you
both at some point back the physical
space at 45 Bleecker Street is a
subculture theater and a not too distant
future goodnight and stay well
[Music]